hey what's up guys
i know i look autistic but i was like
this before the vaccine too
i got the vaccine or i was like to call
it western acupuncture
only one needle not very strong
um but yeah i'm autistic which sucks
because it's the only disease that you
can diagnose in a bar
i've never been drinking and heard
something like hey this guy has
non-hodgkin's lymphoma
that's the jager balls of this guy he's
got cancer
no one ever does that for them but a lot
of my police were like yeah you're spoke
smart but i'm street smart
i was like oh you're smart in a way
that's not measurable or comparable
i'm convenient for you
maybe you're dumb and you're insecure
about it and that's when you committed
aggravated assault
stop punching me it hurts
um my bullies you know they're i grew up
very gender fluid i was biologically
male but my bullies identified me as a
[ __ ]
i do not consent to this gender
[Applause]
um but yeah i think uh it's not to do
with my name my name is hans kim
my parents named me hans because they
didn't want kids at school to make fun
of me for having an
asian name so they give me a german one
instead
[Applause]
and i flew right into the radar
that was close they had no idea i was
asian
foolproof planned parents
hans kim is a german korean name so that
means that
i celebrate oktoberfest by drinking
rice wine which means i bratwurst but
only if they're made out of golden
retrievers
and that means i hate japanese people
only if they're jewish
arrogant and proud
worst combination i think i have a funny
name but i think he's even funnier that
tanner is a white person's name
banner than what you white [ __ ]
should be like hey this is my mexican
friend tanner
that's my black friend tanist
just a suffix joke
i love stand-up comedy but sometimes i
don't show as a painter because i've
never been painting a picture and had
the canvas be like boo
that doesn't look like a tree you should
kill yourself
draw something asian
i used to date a beautiful lady who was
really into yoga and choke sex and i was
do you enjoy breathing or not
[Applause]
i hope you're reminded millennial
i saw a sign in my neighborhood it says
20 miles per hour when children
are present but how fast do i drive as
the children are drawing in the past
i hate carpool lanes because like
society saying hey you know how you're
lonely
yeah do it for longer you lose
[Applause]
watch people with friends whizzing by
you
going too
but uh i don't understand all the
sayings that i hear uh they say prison
don't drop the soap
it should be don't pick up the soap
you can drop as much soap as you want so
bending over when it really gets you
even if you don't drop the soap you're
still getting it right you're just going
to have really clean hands while it
happens
why is this working
who are these rapists that are like man
i want to get that kid but i never
knocked some soap
does he have a butthole no no no
rape or something like that they're
gonna take
but i am single i have uh yet to meet my
soul mate i begin to think maybe it's
her fault she needs to get out more
she seems like a
do loser um i uh
i i get made fun of a lot from being an
asian man and having an asian penis
they think it's tiny but it's not too
big
even if it was it's not like we'd be
like oh we got small dicks okay we'll go
find a new hobby sorry to bother you
i want to just give up we start studying
because that's what we do
we learn how to use it like a sewing
machine
another thing people think that asian
women are beautiful
and not asian men but how do you think
asian women are created
me [ __ ] i'm a crucial part of the
sexy process
please stop trying to skip me if you
have sex with me our children will be
very beautiful
half of them other half will be great
engineers and that support too
i think asian women are uh they act like
they're hotter than asian men but we
look exactly the same [ __ ]
why are you bragging that you can [ __ ]
white dudes
i can [ __ ] with you
you know avoid these
i think they have the sexiest gender in
the human race definitely in the top 32.
i don't think i can ever have sex with
the fellas sorry dudes
uh i've never looked at a beautiful
woman and been like is there a version
of her that's bigger and hairier and
there's less kindness
i want to put that in my butthole
never happens straight as [ __ ] please
believe me my dad doesn't
my dad's like dude we're so lucky we're
not gay can you imagine that most of the
gender you were attracted to wasn't
attracted to you back
and i was like whoa can't even imagine
they was crying a lot
those games
but i think women are very beautiful you
know i'm a sapiosexual that means i'm
looking for a girlfriend who is
intellectually stimulated by the mental
exercise of finding me attractive
like a woman is into puzzles
i was talking to this girl and she was
like did you know that because i can
make a baby my vagina is technically a
3d printer
i was like actually your womb is a 3d
printer
your vagina's a tray
it only prints one thing with lots of
errors
it takes nine months to print the whole
time it's printing is complaining
needless to say and that's any traits at
night
and i love the ladies my friends are
always like dude you need to learn how
to talk to women
maybe or maybe women should learn how to
listen to hans
why don't you want to hear about the
federal reserve
we're at a party come on um
i think it's a good thing that women get
burned i feel like if men gave birth
we'd be like bro i've been eating so
much protein and creatine during my
pregnancy
this baby's like 27 pounds already bro
check out a six-pack of the ultrasound
[Applause]
about those gains in the first trimester
um i'm not a racist i think i should
tell you guys that
i don't even see race i don't like smell
it
i hate racism but i was on a plane once
and i saw a dude reading a book in
arabic which kind of freaked me out
but then i saw him pull the corner of
the page and put the book away and i was
like oh thank god he's got future plans
only an idiot would kill himself in the
middle of a narrative structure
not a racist i i think my
my favorite marvel movie is the black
panther movie because it gave black
children a hero they could finally look
up to
and not just someone like martha king jr
or malcolm x or harriet tubman george
mccarver
freddie gomez
what are they gonna come out with our
movie huh the yellow panda
he's gonna eat your furniture
i love being asian because whenever
someone is racist to me i'm like oh you
hate respectful people
who keep to themselves okay good luck
finding an affordable car
a lot of people make fun of asians
because we dogs which i understand can
be very shocking because an american
dogs are treated like family members but
in asia we treat our family members like
family members
it's weird little tradition we have
where instead of buying an
animal we love our grandma
shoot everyone better in asia unless
you're a baby girl always could see 30
in the river
don't look at the river
but that's what been my time